Democrats in the Judiciary Committee
hold the Attorney General in contempt
and they declare a constitutional crisis
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show man for being in the middle of a
constitutional crisis it's kind of a
nice day Riley's kid okay outside
nobody's killing each other in the
streets doesn't seem a lot of civil war
happening I'm not hearing the zombie
screaming or anything so pretty pretty
calm Placid constitutional crisis we'll
get to the massive constitutional crisis
2019 in just a second but first it's
spring the time of year when seeds grow
into flowers and you grow up financially
at least your family needs protection if
something happens to you that means you
need life insurance thankfully policy
June just makes it easy to get that
financial security without the growing
pains policy genius is the easy way to
buy life insurance online in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers and find your best price once
you apply the policy genius team will
handle all the paperwork and the red
tape as well no Commission's no hidden
fees just financial protection and peace
of my nose strings attached and policy
genius doesn't just simplify life
insurance they also do home insurance
auto insurance disability insurance so
the next time you stop to smell the
roses pull out your phone head on over
to policy genius.com policy genius
spring is here kick it off by nipping
life insurance in the bud be a
responsible human being adult you don't
want to leave your family bereft and
without any source of monetary revenue
if you should kick the bucket so make
sure that you go over to policy genius
right now check it out it only takes a
couple of minutes to get competing rates
and then buy yourself some life
insurance and make sure your family is
taking care of policy genius.com go
check it out right now policy genius
calm okay so the big story of the day
the Democrats moving forward with their
contempt charges against Attorney
General William bar now one of the
problems with this contempt charge is
that it's really really stupid so as
David French the legal analyst and
National Review pointed out yesterday on
our radio show David French pointed out
william bar originally had no obligation
to turn over any of the Mullah report he
decided to turn over virtually all of
the mother report in fact when I say
virtually all of the Mullen report Jack
crow over a National Review reports that
top Democrats now have access to all but
two full and said
partial lines of Robert Muller's
obstruction report he says as
congressional Democrats prepare to hold
Attorney General William Barton contempt
over his supposed lack of transparency
it's worth remembering he is made
available to top Democrats at the
entirety of volume 2 of the mellow
report saved for two full and seven
partial lines which were redacted to
protect grand jury secrecy in keeping
with federal law in order to provide
lawmakers with greater transparency into
special counsel Robert Mullins
investigation the Department of Justice
placed a less redacted version of his
report in a secure room on Capitol Hill
and granted access to that room to
congressional leaders of both parties as
well as the Chairman and ranking members
of intelligence and judiciary committees
in the House and Senate as of this
writing not one of the six Democrats
granted access to what amounts to 99.9%
of volume two of the malla report which
details the president's behavior as it
relates to obstruction of justice have
taken the opportunity to examine it so
just to get this straight they have now
made available to top Democrats the
entirety of the Mellon report with the
exception of two full full lines in four
and FortiGate pages two full lines and
seven partial lines now one Democrat has
done this and they can't they have the
option to do so if they had they could
have viewed the entirety of Muller's
obstruction cased against Trump except
for seven redactions two of which are
applied to footnotes in response to bars
offer congressional Democrats have said
the full report should be made available
to all lawmakers why if they know only
we look at what's there now the reason
they won't look at what's there is
because if they look at what's there
then they will have to admit that there
really isn't much additionally that is
there that is damaging to the President
of the United States undoubtedly they
say the full report should be made
available to all lawmakers they've
argued the outcome will become less
likely if top congressman view the less
redacted version so in other words if
they go and see the West redacted
version they're afraid the argument will
be taken away from them that bar is
being non transparent well that's
because bar is is actually not being non
transparent he's being quite transparent
here mark warner the ranking Democrat on
the Senate Intelligence Committee told
John McCormack every member of Congress
ought to be able to see that version I
think if I were to go
you'd lessen the case but Democratic
leaders are not asking for that version
which retains the grand jury reactions
they're asking for a fully unredacted
report and all of the millions of pages
of under law
documentary evidence which relates to 22
ongoing criminal investigations now as I
mentioned yesterday it is against the
law for William Parr to actually comply
with the subpoena request Federal Rule
of Criminal Procedure six e prevents the
disclosure of grand jury information
Federal Rule of Criminal Procedure six e
is not unclear about this in fact it's
quite clear about this it says that you
are not allowed to reveal all of this
stuff you cannot do that because if you
do you could be exposing to both
criticism and censure people on the
basis of non evidenced theories that are
often put out there and grand jury
testimony according to rule 6 e secrecy
must be the rule of the day once a grand
jury is summoned you are not allowed to
put out the information that is said in
the grand jury summons you can't do that
so this is this is ridiculous basically
the Democrats the Congress created rule
6 e cabe rule 6 e is a congressionally
created rule the fact that Democrats are
now saying that William bar should be
held in contempt for obeying the law is
pretty insane according to rule 6 e no
obligation of secrecy may be imposed on
any person except in accordance with
rule 6 e to be unless these rules
provide otherwise the following persons
must not disclose a matter occurring
before the grand jury a grand juror an
interpreter a court reporter an operator
of a recording device
a person who transcribed recorded
testimony an attorney for the government
not allowed to disclose a matter
occurring before the grand jury
disclosure of a grand jury matter may be
made only to an attorney for the
government for use in performing the
attorneys duty any government personnel
that an attorney for the government
considers necessary to assist in
performing that attorneys duty to
enforce federal criminal law which does
not apply to Congress or a person
authorized by a different section of
statute which does not apply to Congress
there's no question that bars
interpretation of this rule is correct
nonetheless Democrats are attempting to
hold him in contempt for what exactly
as I said yesterday the assistant
attorney general Stephen Boyd he says as
we've repeatedly explained the Attorney
General could not comply with your
subpoena in its current form without
violating the law court rules and court
orders and without threatening the
Independence of the Department of
Justice's prosecutorial functions White
House press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders said faced with terminate lers
blatant abuse of power and at the
attorney general's request the president
has no option no other option than to
make a protective assertion of executive
privilege
so there are two issues here one is bar
right to reject material the answer is
yes to is whether executive privilege
applies here the answer there is really
no the answer there is that executive
privilege doesn't really apply formally
in law and it's more of a delay tactic
because bar is right about the federal
rules but executive privilege likely
does not apply here as we discussed
yesterday there are two types of
executive privilege deliberative process
privilege and communications privilege
both types of privilege do create a
presumption of privilege for the
president that presumption can be
overruled by a court and it's awkward to
fit any of this into the privilege box
that's particularly true since William
bar has openly suggested that executive
privilege was not declared by the
president so if executive privilege
wasn't declared over any of the mellow
report before it's hard to then put that
genie back in the bottle and suggest
that executive privilege can be declared
now I mean William bar said this this is
back in in April when he first gave his
four-page synopsis here was William bar
saying the president has not declared
executive privilege over all this stuff
now I guess he's saying that he's gonna
go back and now declare retroactive
executive privilege I'm not sure that
that works the decision whether to
assert executive privilege over any
portion of the report rested with the
President of the United States
significant portions of the report
contain material over which the
president could have asserted privilege
and he would have been well within his
rights to do so following my March 29th
letter the office of the White House
Council requested the opportunity to
review the redacted version of the
report following that review the
president confirmed that in the interest
of transparency and full disclosure to
the American people he would not assert
privilege over the special counsels
pork no material has been redacted based
on executive privilege okay so you know
the fact that that William bard did not
declare executive privilege before means
it's very difficult for him to clear
executive privilege now but that's a
different question from whether he is
doing something that is illegal or
obstructive the answer there is no he is
trying to protect himself from violating
federal criminal law and Democrats of
course have jumped at this they've
manufactured this entire crisis they
couldn't get what they wanted from the
Mullen report so now they're trying to
create a presumption of new obstruction
so the Mullen report does not actually
result in criminal prosecution of the
President of the United States for
obstruction of justice and so Democrats
are trying to now suggest well there's
no obstruction occurring it's nonsense
but this is what Democrats are gonna
push forward with Nancy Pelosi says you
know what we have to hold will do it
William bar in contempt for what well
because he hasn't given us the material
that he's given us that I can look at in
conjunction with federal law here's
Nancy Pelosi making this foolish and
dishonest case yes I think that the
Attorney General should be held in
contempt this contempt is about two
withholding of the Muller report in an
unredacted way we all agree that certain
things should be redacted but they were
in the course of accommodations and boom
the administration just said if you
don't you know we're going to make this
executive privilege more on the subject
than you ever want to know yes should be
held in contempt okay so this of course
is a completely manufactured crisis
nonetheless Democrats are looking for a
manufactured crisis so they can suggest
that Trump is breaking all the
institutional rules they have this
theory their theory is that Trump was
going to come into government with a
wrecking bar basically and then he was
going to destroy the in who's going to
destroy all the institutions of
government that has not happened
meanwhile Democrats have declared that
the Senate of the United States should
be abolished the Supreme Court should be
packed that we should change all of the
voter ID laws that the electoral college
should be abolished and that they should
be able to override any congressional
action with an executive order
effectively Democrats have declared all
of these things but it's Donald Trump
who's a threat to the institutional
integrity of the United States so to
build that case they want to say that
right now Trump is engaged in some sort
of usurpation of authority
threatens the constitutional structure
as we'll see in a second this is sheer
and absolute nonsense we'll get to that
but first we need to talk about how you
hire better okay the reality is that
you're always trying to make your hiring
better and the only way to do that
really is to use zip recruiter hiring
used to be hard multiple job sites
stacks of resumes a confusing review
process today
hiren can be easy you only have to go to
one place to get it done zip recruiter
comm slash daily wire zip recruiter
sends your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and then invites them to
apply to your job as applications come
in zip recovery analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match
zip recruiter is so effective planned
for out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire that is zip recruiter comm slash a
daily wired Dai ly w ir e zip recruiter
comm
slash daily wire zip recruiter is indeed
the smartest way to hire go check them
out at zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire and try it out for free ok so
Democrats have declared constitutional
crisis Jerry Nadler who I am old enough
to remember when Jerry Nadler was saying
that it was not a constitutional crisis
when Bill Clinton was overtly
obstructing justice also this is the
same Jerry Nadler who actually walked
out on a contempt vote on Eric Holder
who it turned out had not actually
turned over all the documents that
William bar has and was not obeying
federal rules of criminal law the way
that William bar is but here is Jerry
Nadler saying no no no this is a
constitutional crisis the head of the
House Judiciary Committee a government
where all the information is in the
executive branch where the American
people and the Congress are stonewalled
is the information that they need to
make decisions and to know what's going
on it's
attack on the will on the ability of the
American people to know what the
executive branch is doing and to have
responsible government it is an attack
on the essence of our democracy and we
must oppose this with every fiber of our
being we've talked for a long time about
approaching a constitutional crisis we
are now in it okay this is an absurdity
on top of an absurdity he's standing
there saying that they don't have the
information that they're being blocked
from the information they will not go
see the information that has been
revealed to them the entire metal report
has been made public even the parts that
are redacted
the vast majority of those redactions
are now available to Jerry Nadler
personally and he's standing there
claiming that he's being blocked from
seeing relevant information it's just
nonsense but this is what Democrats are
gonna push out there and all day on CNN
this is being parotid constitutional
crisis constitutional crisis you got
Sheila jackson-lee saying the president
is taking a wrecking ball to the
Constitution of the United States Sheila
jackson-lee
I can only conclude that the president
now seeks to take a wrecking ball
through the Constitution of the United
States of America okay representative
jayapal says this is one of the most
serious constitutional moments we've
ever faced ever ever one of the most
serious come really
we've had some pretty serious
constitutional moments like FDR trying
to pack the Supreme Court or maybe like
a civil war in the United States or even
Barack Obama attempting to simply go
around the law to shape his immigration
views but jayapal says this is one of
the most serious constitutional moments
in American history because they have
access to a report that they are lying
and say they don't have access to I
really think that this is one of the
most serious if not the most serious
constitutional moment that we have faced
we are at a deeply disturbing moment in
our country's history the difference
between a dictatorship and a democracy
is that a democracy has checks and
balances if you take away the entire
authority and say one branch is not
going to respect the authority of the
other then I think we every American
should be deeply concerned okay that
last statement is simply hilarious she
says if you take away the checks and
balances by saying that one branch
doesn't have to respect the other branch
then we won't have checks and balances
any more um no a check and a balance is
the executive also checking and
balancing the legislature
talk about checks and balances for a
second so in Federalist 51 the founders
focused on the fact that checks and
balances meant there would be gridlock
it meant that government would be messy
it meant that ambition would check
ambition Federalist 51 probably most
famous of the Federalist Papers because
it has one of the great expressions of
governmental philosophy in human history
they say ambition this is Hamilton and
Madison ambition must be made to
counteract ambition the interests of the
man must be connected with the
constitutional rights of the place it
may be a reflection on human nature that
such devices should be necessary to
control the abuses of government but
what is government itself but the
greatest of all reflections on human
nature if men were angels no government
would be necessary if angels were to
govern men neither external nor internal
controls on government would be
necessary in framing a government which
is to be administered by men over men
the great difficulty lies in this you
must first enable the government to
control the government the governed and
in the next place oblige you to control
itself in other words if people were
inherently good you don't need
government if people were inherently bad
there'd be no way to control them but
because people are capable of both good
and bad you need people to checked each
other and that is why there are checks
and balances what we are watching here
is the proper exercise of those checks
and balances Federalist 51 talks about
the fact that the legislature is
extraordinarily powerful but that needs
to be checked by the abilities of the
executive they say that you need a
powerful executive an executive powerful
enough to be able to check the
legislature the legislature has its own
independent investigative powers so when
they say that all of the information in
grand jury proceedings pursued by the
executive branch should be open in
violation of the federal rules of
criminal law to the Congress what they
are really doing is manufacturing a
crisis and then declaring the President
Trump is a dictator for exercising his
normal powers now again executive
privilege is not properly applied here
but the fact that this is even an issue
in the first place is truly ridiculous
hey Adam Schiff is going around saying a
guy who spent two years proclaiming that
he had secret information showing the
President Trump was actually a Russian
stooge he's a damned liar Adam shift
here's the Adam Schiff going around
saying well you know now we're gonna
have to prosecute people because of this
constitutional crisis okay you go ahead
and do that and then the executive
branch won't do anything about it
because let's say that Congress held
William Barton criminal
contempt the only way for that to result
in a conviction is for the executive
branch to prosecute William Bar guess
who's the head of the Department of
Justice William Bar so that is the thing
that's not going to happen if Congress
wants they can impeach him if they
impeach William bar for following the
law and giving Congress all the
information that he can legally give
them that is an absurdity piled on top
of an absurdity here's Adam Schiff a
truly dishonest human being if the
administration continues this
across-the-board refusal to comply with
any legal process from the Congress any
oversight by the Congress then we have
no choice that we're gonna have to
prosecute this through a contempt we're
moving forward and in our own committee
because we have a separate basis for
getting all the counterintelligence
information in the report the underlying
documents but they're equally
stonewalling us okay so no that is none
of that is true it is hilarious that the
media will continue to parrot this
nonsense president Trump is exactly
right here when he says that the fake
news will say the Trump wants to break
the Constitution he's exactly right he
did a rally last night in Florida here's
one of the things that he said I call
him the fakers fake news media
they are a bunch of fakers there's no
question about it but you know in six
years they're all gonna be out of
business folks watched it'll be
headlines tomorrow Donald Trump wants to
break constitutionality okay so he is
right that's what the media will do now
I will point out in Nancy Pelosi who was
saying that we have to hold William bar
in contempt here's what Nancy Pelosi
said when Eric Holder the former
attorney general was held in contempt
for failing to turn over 1,300 pages of
subpoenaed documents on fast and furious
and there was no internal investigation
made public to Congress at that time
here was Nancy Pelosi there's just a few
years ago talking about the vote to hold
attorney General Holder in contempt what
we have seen is a shameful display of
abuse of power by the Republicans in the
House of Representatives instead of
bringing job-creating creating
legislation to the floor the
transportation bill they are holding the
Attorney General of the United States in
contempt of Congress for doing his job
these very same people are holding him
in contempt are part of a nationwide
scheme to suppress the vote okay that's
that's what's happening here is that
they're going after Eric Holder to
suppress the vote or something I mean
this is it that's what Nancy Pelosi said
years ago about Congress holding an
Attorney General in contempt now she
wants to hold William bar in contempt
for doing nothing it's amazing
here's Jay Carney the former spokesman
for the White House under Barack Obama
saying that the attempt to hold Eric
Holder in contempt was just political
theater his position pretty clear on
this and it's highly political in nature
what you're hearing from me is are the
views of the president and the White
House the administration that this is a
political theater it is
unnecessary distraction from the work
that Congress should be doing for the
American people on the economy on jobs
and you know I think many Americans most
Americans will view it that way
okay so again it's hilarious to watch as
the Democrats shift their stance on this
dramatically in order to go after a guy
who is significantly less guilty of
anything then Eric Holder the
president's self-described wingman was
at the time
speaking of crimes that Democrats are
willing to ignore representative Hakeem
Jeffries of New York he came out
yesterday and he said that the big
problem in this whole in this whole
thing one of the big problems is that
President Trump has embarrassed Peter
struck and Lisa Paige those were the
paramore FBI agents who were
manipulating the process in both the
Hillary investigation and the Trump
investigation not according to me
according to the Inspector General of
the DOJ Michael Horowitz
here's representative Justin Jeffries
saying you know we really should let
struck and Paige off the hook so let's
get this straight
according to Hakeem Jeffries and folks
like him Democrats Peter struck and Lisa
Paige who openly texted each other about
insurance plans against Trump becoming
president and about how terrible Trump
was well investigating Trump those
people just made mistakes and Trump is
mean for embarrassing them but William
Barr who was handed over all the
materials he can legally hand over he's
a bad guy we should impeach many of my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle actually perpetrated a witch-hunt
as it relates to securing more than
800,000 documents from this very same
Department of Justice without regard to
the reputation of interest of Americans
who have served this country you aren't
concerned with the reputation or
interest of Peter struck and Lisa Paige
in fact you embarrassed those two okay
so you made mistakes
Wow you embarrass them so terrible I
mean it's very bad to embarrass Peter
struck and Lisa Paige who are
effectively fired under under cloudy
circumstance and then condemned by the
IG that's bad but Eric Holder but but
rather William bar should be held in
contempt pretty amazing stuff in a
second we will get to the the latest
attempts to railroad President Trump to
kind of box him into a corner with more
skin
investigations we'll get to that in a
second first we're never going to agree
on everything but I think we can all
agree that we could use more sleep
getting a great night's sleep is easier
more affordable than you think you don't
need a new expensive mattress or
sleeping pills you just need to change
your sheets that's why you should check
out bull and branch everything bull and
branch makes from bedding to blankets is
made from pure 100% organic cotton it
means they start out super soft they get
even softer over time you buy directly
from them so you're essentially paying
wholesale prices I know you think you
can just get sheets off the shelf and
you the thread count will tell you
everything you need to know not true
what you need our luxury sheets that
don't cost luxury prices and this is
where bull and branch comes in these
sheets can cost up to a thousand bucks
in the store sheets like this bull and
bran sheets just a couple of hundred
bucks everyone who tries bull and bran
sheets loves them that's why they have
thousands of five-star views really I
didn't think I'd feel the difference and
then I tried ball and bran sheets and I
really do they are so comfortable three
former US presidents sleep on pole and
branch sheets shipping is free you can
try them for 30 nights if you don't love
them send the back for a refund but
you're not going to want to in fact
they're so good I got rid of all the
other sheets in my house and only have
Boleyn branch at this point to get you
started right now my listeners get 50
bucks off your first set of sheets at
bowl and branch calm promo code Ben go
to bowl and branch calm today 50 bucks
off your first set of sheets that's bol
l and branch calm promo code Ben bull
and branch calm promo code Ben okay so
meanwhile and the the attempts to go
after president Trump for scandals
continues even though there's really not
a lot of evidence of scandal so for
example the New York Times today is
going after President Trump over his tax
returns again this time based on the New
York Times report suggesting he lost a
lot of money in the 1980s and early
1990s the editorial board says president
from owes the American people a fuller
account of his financial dealings
including the release of his recent tax
returns because politicians should keep
their promises because the public
deserves to know whether his policies
are lining his pockets and because the
integrity of our system of government
requires everyone particularly the
president to obey the law here's the
question the IRS audits people they do
if they think President Trump is
committing a crime wouldn't the IRS be
looking into auditing him I mean he says
he's under audit maybe he's lying but
the IRS has the capacity to prosecute
tax fraud as a private citizen is still
tax fraud has there been any indication
that Trump has committed a crime here
we keep hearing rumors of crime but the
IRS audits people all the time and then
works with the Department of Justice to
prosecute people on a regular basis
apparently the New York Times just once
his tax returns to humiliate him we all
know really why President Trump is not
releasing his tax returns okay the real
reason President Trump is not releasing
his tax returns is because those tax
returns are going to say that he is not
as rich as he says he is that's why it's
the reason why he was embarrassed by
that story a little bit earlier this
week that he lost like a billion dollars
in the 80s and early 90s he's the only
one I think who cares about this maybe
the New York Times cares about it too I
had always assumed he was not worth
nearly as much money as he said that he
was I always thought he was lying about
his level of wealth that's what he does
he's a showman
he's a bloviator he's been doing it on
TV for years he's a guy who gets himself
posed on the cover of Playboy like that
that's what Donald Trump is this is part
of the package either love the package
or you hate the package or your
indifference in the package and you care
about the policies but the New York
Times trying to gin up some sort of
scandal by declaring a scandal when
there is none it's pretty amazing
you remember that Harry Reid did the
same thing to MIT Romney suggested that
MIT Romney had committed some sort of
tax fraud that he'd never paid any taxes
and then it turned out MIT Romney had
paid a higher effective tax rate than a
lot of Americans and was giving a full
10% of everything he made to charity
like millions and millions of dollars
but this is a typical tactic at this
point they say well you know mr. Trump
might hold money in foreign tax havens
those investments would be listed
what if Trump deducted the interest
payments on a loan from his taxable
income he'd be required to disclose
information about the source and amount
of the loan so now they're just
speculating about what exactly is in his
tax returns now I think his tax returns
should be released I like more
information about our politicians I
think that's a good thing but the
attempt to speculate about what is in
the tax returns I don't really see the
moral difference between this and the
push back when Barack Obama was
president suggesting that Obama's
reluctance to release his birth
certificate meant who's born in Kenya
it's speculation on the basis of lack of
information is not actually information
it's just speculation and very often
it's stupid speculation one thing I
think we can fairly clearly say is there
is no evidence that Trump has committed
a tax crime it's a lake here's the new
your tent is the Editorial Board of the
New York Times the returns also
could help to clarify whether mr. Trump
continues to cheat on his taxes we have
an entire service it's called the
Internal Revenue Service that does this
sort of stuff it's pretty incredible
but I guess that they are sort of
relegated to trying to dig up crimes
because the mobile report did not give
Democrats precisely what they wanted
meanwhile the Senate Intelligence
Committee has subpoenaed Donald Trump
jr. according to the Associated Press
the Senate Intelligence Committee has
subpoenaed Trump jr. by calling him in
to answer questions about his 2017
testimony to the panel as part of its
probe into Russian election interference
that's according to two people familiar
with the subpoena who discussed it on
condition of anonymity unclear from
tuner will comply with the subpoena a
person close to the president's held his
son said Wednesday has continued to
cooperate by producing documents and
answering written questions the person
called the new request of public
relations stunts and criticized at North
Carolina Republican Senator Richard burr
for calling Donald Trump jr. in the
committee had renewed interest in
talking to Trump jr. after Michael Cohen
testified earlier this year Cohen had
told the House committee in February
he'd briefed Trump jr. approximately 10
times about a plan to build a Trump
Tower in Moscow before the presidential
election from a worldly perspective
Trump jr. would be a fool to appear in
front of the committee again after all
of this nonetheless the idea that this
is some sort of nefarious action by
Richard Burr I find hard to believe the
Senate Intel committee has been
investigating Russian election
interference for the last two years
they're trying to call in a bunch of
witness witnesses as they wind up their
own investigation over the next several
months the subpoena does put burr at
odds with some of his Republican
colleagues we'd like this to be over
after the Muller report Rand Paul took a
shot at Senator Burr after the subpoena
was reported tweeting apparently the
Republican chair of the Senate Intel
committee didn't get the memo from the
majority leader that this case was
closed I really doubt that that Trump
jr. complies with the subpoena if they
hold him in contempt he probably figures
okay whatever who exactly cares
meanwhile Democrats are neglecting the
fact that Trump is still Trump and that
if they want to beat Trump they're going
to have to run against candidate Trump
now this would be an epic time for a
good trump bad Trump episode I know we
haven't had a good Trump bad Trump
episode really since campaign 2016 but
as
entra campaign 2020 we're gonna have to
revive the good Trump bad Trump axis
through which we see the presidents of
the United States we even had a theme
song going back a few years for good
Trump bad from which we will have to dig
up and use in the future
shouldn't old my producers to do it
earlier in any case today's episode of
good Trump bad Trump Trump did a rally
in Florida and at that rally he said
some good things and at that rally he
said some not good things and we will
talk about those things coming up in
just one second first running a small
business is a lot of work it takes time
and money you want all the time and
money you have to go toward growing your
business but what happens when legal
hurdles pop up along the way LegalZoom
is there to help nearly 2 million
Americans have used Legal Zoom to start
their businesses with LLC's
incorporation and more but even after
your business is set up Legal Zoom can
still help you out things like lease
agreements changing tax laws contract
reviews all of these are part of running
your own business these are precisely
the kinds of costly hurdles that can
take time away from growing your
business
that's why Legal Zoom created their
business legal plan get advice for
running your business from vetted
independence attorneys and tax
professionals available in all 50 states
I know legal is a giant pain in the rear
but this is why Legal Zoom is so
important the best part of this you
won't get charged by the hour because
Legal Zoom is not a law firm make your
time and money work for you check out
Legal Zoom is misleading plan at
legalzoom.com right now get special
savings when you enter been at checkout
Legal Zoom is where life meets legal
legalzoom.com I've been using Legal Zoom
myself for years as a lawyer I am
constantly looking for ways to save
money on legal costs Legal Zoom is one
way to do it go check out their business
legal plan right now at legalzoom.com
and enter code been a check out for
special savings ok we're gonna get to
good Trump bad from in just a second
plus an amazing spectacle as students in
Colorado walk out of what turns into a
propaganda rally on behalf of gun
control after school shooting and to all
that stuff in just a second first you're
gonna have to go over to Daily wire calm
and subscribe go over to daily where
calm $9.99 a month means you get a
subscription that means two additional
hours of me everyday and that we have
all sorts of fantastic guests we're on
every single day and two additional
hours of my analysis as the news
develops over the course of the day so
basically this shows like an all-day
show and you get constant access to it
when you go to daily wear icon plus we
have our Sunday specials available on
Saturday plus we have daily wear
backstage where you can ask questions
plus we have the conversation where you
can ask me personally questions plus
sometimes now increasingly rare
occasions but sometimes we answer
questions during the breaks of the radio
show all three minutes of those breaks
so you get all sorts of goodies when you
become a subscriber also you help us
insure ourselves against the
vicissitudes of many of our social media
betters you get all that stuff when you
become a daily wire subscriber and when
you spend 99 bucks a year you get this
the very greatest in beverage vessels
behold its glory the leftist tears hot
or cold tumblr and get that to show to
all of your leftist friends and then you
get to collect their tears in a constant
never-ending supply go check all of that
out right now please subscribe at
YouTube and iTunes as well we always
appreciate it
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so let's talk about this at
this Trump rally last night so at the
Trump rally last night he showed his
strength he showed his weakness Trump is
a man in full so the President of the
United States he made a good point when
it comes to illegal immigration he said
look when it comes to illegal
immigration there's someone who takes it
seriously namely me and then there are
Democrats who do not the Democrats don't
want a wall I do that's a pretty clear
contrast we need Democrats in Congress
to work with us to pass an acceptable
bill we're getting close it's pretty
tough dealing with bid they don't want
to build a wall but we're building the
wall they don't want to do a lot of okay
now with a crisis on a bore on the
border that even the Democrats are
beginning to acknowledge the crisis on
the border acknowledged openly by the
New York Times editorial board Trump has
a leg to stand on right here and the
fact that Democrats continue to to
stymie him when it comes to enforcement
of the border is definitely a point
against them and Trump is correct by the
way that among the Democrats there are
certain candidates who are not exactly
going to be imposing two are two people
with whom they negotiate p-put a judge
is the one that that Trump decides to
pick on right here now that is not a rip
on mayor Pete's military experience
which indeed is more than I've done more
than Trump has done more than most
people have done but it is to pick on
his persona which is that he is going to
concede to foreign adversaries when it
comes to negotiations because his
worldview is in line with that here's
Trump on budda judge whose image is sort
of as as a european-style
european-style leader they say edge edge
he's got a great chance says he he'll be
great he'll be great representing us
against President Xi of China that'll be
great that'll be great
I want to be in that room I want to
watch that one okay Trump's whole shtick
is that obviously he's a tough
negotiator and he has apparently been
holding China's feet to the fire you
know Trump on attack like that
there's something in Trump has an an
airing instinct for sticking the knife
in the change in people's armor right he
just he does it is it is what he is
great at and that
is why he is a dangerous candidate in a
binary race President Trump has a he's
like an insult comedian he's like
triumph the insult comic dog right he's
really good at tearing people down so
all of that is good Trump when it comes
to campaigning and then there's bad
Trump and my my estimable purdue
producers for bad Trump have already
found the song I referenced earlier the
good Trump bad Trump jingle let's play
it
[Music]
well the answer was both so he got
President Trump on the trail in Florida
promoting his immigration plan and then
he got president from doing that this is
the problem being an insult comic
sometimes you're so eager to play to the
crowd that you end up giving credence
and credibility to people who do not
deserve it so here's the president last
night talking about border patrol and
talking about how Border Patrol has to
treat people humanely and then somebody
says something bad and then President
Trump turns it into a joke sort of this
is not good now again there are a lot of
people today we're going to point out
the media are over playing their hand on
this one that is true they are over
playing their hand on this one with that
said is this good no it's not here's the
President of the United States last
night using the word invasion it's an
invasion and it's also an invasion of
drugs coming in from Mexico okay but how
do you stop these people
you can't this
that's only in the Panhandle you can get
away with that steak okay so what
happened is how do you stop these people
and somebody shouted you shoot them and
then Trump jokes
well only in the Panhandle could you get
away with that well right before that
that's not in that clip right before
that he says don't forget we don't let
them and we can't let them use weapons
he talked about border agents we can't
other countries do we can't I would
never do that
but how do you stop these people and
then somebody shouted shoot them and
then he and then he made a joke you can
only say that in the Panhandle you can
only say that the Panhandle now here is
the problem this is another sort of
classic example of how President Trump
in his effort to joke or in his effort
to avoid in his effort to please the
crowd in front of him ends up getting
given credibility to bad positions and
he does this fairly frequently like he
was speaking to a crowd of cops I think
a couple of years ago and he started
talking about you know I'd be great if
you could just rough these people
obviously you can't but it'd be great if
he were me I would just let you ruff
ruff these guys up in the back of a van
it was effectively what he said and he
was joking because he was trying to
please the crowd and people said
correctly you're the President of the
United States you shouldn't be praising
people for roughing people up right the
you you're not an insult comic in fact
you're the President of the United
States well this one falls under the
words of the President of the United
States matter even though we all sort of
discount them because we know who he is
so the media of course are playing this
up all the way suggesting the president
Trump actually is in favor of shooting
immigrants even though he specifically
said that he would not do that he
doesn't like that and then he made a
joke to somebody because this is what he
does he makes jokes so this one falls
under bad Trump now I know there are a
lot of Trump fans who say well it's not
bad Trump that's just people who are
deciding to be too serious people who
are deciding to take him too literally
again I hold him to the same standard I
would hold any other president I
understand I don't take him as seriously
when he does these sorts of things as I
would a Barack Obama or a George W Bush
because that's not who he is as a
personality is it good that the
President of the United States is
turning shoot shoot illegal immigrants
into a joking line on the campaign trail
no it's not even if he is explicitly
saying that he is against doing that and
this sort of falls under the same
category to a certain extent is sort of
the charlottesville second take right
originally Donald Trump's take on
charlottesville was that he condemned
everybody
he said there was there is all sorts of
bad stuff happening on all sides those
his original take and he didn't
specifically single out white
supremacist and then in his revised take
he said I condemn fully the neo-nazis I
condemn fully the white supremacist but
there were people who are marching who
were good people because there were good
people on both sides unnecessary
pandering to a crowd a mistake ok so
that's the problem with good Trump
bedroom so Trump pleases the crowd in
front of him sometimes at the expense of
the crowd beyond the camera and this is
going to give Democrats some room to run
when he really did not have to do so so
this is the this is what Democrat
Democrat have some material to work with
when it comes to President Trump
obviously the fact that they're focusing
in on scandal suggests they don't think
that he's quite as vulnerable as they
say that he as they say they believe he
is which is kind of amazing it's kind of
amazing
all right meanwhile in a in a terrible
story obviously over the last couple of
days there was a school shooting that
happened in Highlands Ranch Colorado
according to the New York Times last
month is the 20th anniversary of the
Columbine High School shooting
approached stem school Highlands Ranch
joined hundreds of schools near Denver
and closing temporarily amid security
concerns but on Tuesday afternoon the
stem schools worst fears were realized
when nine of its students were shot one
fatally to fellow students were being
held as suspects we know two individuals
walked into the stem school got deep
inside the school engaged students in
two separate locations according to
Sheriff Tony Spurlock of Douglas County
at 6:45 p.m. about five hours after the
shooting the Douglas County Sheriff's
Office released a statement confirming
that one of the nine who had been shot
an eighteen year old man had died late
Tuesday night the Sheriff's Office
identified one of the suspects but said
it would provide no further information
about him I don't mention the name of
mass shooters on the show because what
we still have interviews to conduct we
want to make sure we have the most
accurate information so obviously
another horrific mass shooting at a
school apparently handguns were used in
the shooting and apparently the person
responsible at least one of the two
suspects responsible is a person who
leaned politically left the reason I
mentioned this is because the media
always making about the politics of the
suspect as opposed to the evil of the
suspect apparently he this person had
said on social media that he hated
Christians specifically for their
teachings on homosexuality and
apparently he hated President
Trump as well he shared video of Seth
Meyers I doubt we were gonna get a lot
of talk about Seth Meyers inciting
violence but apparently this is what
this this human piece of debris did and
now all of this broke out into the open
yesterday not just because of the
shooting but because of the reaction to
the shooting so the reaction to the
shooting was pretty amazing
naturally the left immediately made it
about gun control because whenever there
is a mass shooting that is carried out
not by a white supremacist then it's
about gun control so if a white
supremacist commits mass shooting it's
about the evils of conservatism which is
conflated with white supremacy in the
left mind and when it is a school
shooting committed by somebody who is
not a white supremacist then it's not
about ideology or incitement at all then
it becomes about guns
well what this resulted in last night
was there was a candlelight vigil and
one of the people who showed up to the
candlelight vigil was an activist for
moms demand action in democratic
congressman Democratic Senator Michael
Bennet and Democratic congressman Jason
crow addressed the crowd and they
started calling for gun control and many
of the kids walked out here's one of the
women who was speaking she was from moms
demand action and calling for gun
control we became paralyzed by the NRA
we did not hold our elected officials
accountable as they were loosening the
sensible gun regulations that were
keeping us safe instead we chose to
burden our youth with the responsibility
of saving their own lives we forced all
of you to learn an environment that's
more closely resembling a prison than a
school none of this is right we robbed
you of your innocence okay so she did
all of this there's this woman from moms
demand action and a bunch of the
students said no you're not going to use
our grief as a platform for your
political agenda and so they walked out
so here's some here's some video and
audio of them walking out of the
auditorium and as you'll hear they they
start chanting mental health because
apparently this person had a mental
health history here's all the students
leaving and saying listen we're not
doing this good for the students good
for the students because this sort of
stuff is used as a platform all too
often not to look not to
look at the actual problems involved in
the specific shooting but to look at
problems that the left would like to
place on the shoulders of a fact pattern
that doesn't actually obtain and one of
the students said what happened at stem
is awful but it's not a statistic we
can't be used as a reason for gun
control were people not a statement
speaking of the lone fatality
18 year old Kendrick Castillo who
apparently was a hero who charged one of
the gunman another student added we
wanted Kendra to be mourned we wanted
all of you to join us in that morning
but that was not allowed here we all
walked out we were not kicked out the
vigil was organized by team enough which
for the student branch of gun control
group the Brady Campaign the kids
chanted mental health and they yelled at
the media because the media frankly
deserve it
the students returned some of them took
the microphone saying their grief was
being used for political purposes good
for them good for them because as I say
the media always have narratives do they
want to draw from these shootings and
invariably those narratives or
narratives they have been pushing in the
absence of the shooting so if there's a
shooting that involves handguns it turns
into a discussion about banning assault
weapons and if there's a shooting that's
really about the mental health of the
suspect then it turns into a discussion
about gun control and if it's a shooting
that is about that is about white
supremacism then they talk about the
ideology and not the guns so it's always
a shifting it's always a shifting mode
it's always a shifting mode and it's
pretty great of the students to have the
intellectual wherewithal and the
intestinal fortitude to walk out of
something like this and say listen if
we're gonna hold a vigil let's hold a
vigil if we're gonna be in solidarity
let's be in solidarity but I'm not gonna
allow politicians to carve us up based
on political political considerations
Nicholas Kristof was doing exactly that
in the pages of the New York Times today
he has a piece today titled we have two
dead young heroes it's time to stand up
to guns
he says politicians fearful of the
National Rifle Association have allowed
the gun lobby to run amok so that
America now has more guns than people
but there are still true heroism out
there in the face of gun violence
students who rushed shooters at the risk
of their own lives but celebrate and
mourn a student in Kendra Castillo a
teen just days away from graduating that
STEM Academy according to another
student Kendrick lunged at him he shot
Kendrick giving all of us enough time to
get underneath our desks get ourselves
safe and to run across the room to
escape at least three boys in the class
one of them Brendan B ow
who hopes to become a Marine tackled and
disarmed the gunmen Bravo as well to the
police officers who arrived within two
minutes of the shooting the courage of
those students echoes last week's
bravery of Riley Howell a student at the
University of North Carolina at
Charlotte Riley 21 charged two gunmen
there and continued even as he was shot
twice as he tackled the gunman who shot
a third time in the head and killed but
he ended the shooting Riley does it was
guilt was deservedly given a hero's
funeral presumably the same will happen
with Kendra but their parents didn't
want martyrs they wanted children and
grandchildren it is appalling that we as
a society have abandoned American kids
so that we must die to save their
classmates so this is the this is again
just the general gun control argument no
no attempt to get in touch with the
families by the way of these heroes and
ask how they felt about gun control or
the students were under fire and asked
how they felt about gun control or even
to look at the actual Studies on gun
control and see whether gun control
would be effective in stopping mass
shootings like this the generalised
answer is no nonetheless the left pushes
for this sort of stuff
and you know as somebody who in the last
several weeks has been the victim of at
least of some death threats bad enough
that it ended with an FBI arrest all I
can say is that our proper solution was
to up security and for me to carry a gun
as much as I legally can and I think
that there should be more armed officers
in these schools but good again good on
the students for doing the right thing
and and not caving to the media push and
by the way it is a media push and it
says that the some of the students were
yelling at the media maybe they were
yelling at the media because you got
bolts like Chris Cuomo who are who are
basically using their platforms as
quote/unquote objective journalists to
push gun control here's Chris Cuomo on
CNN being very objective and very
journalism 'ok here he is these
conversations you've how many of you
heard how many families like that we're
gonna have an argument for you tonight
that shouldn't have to be made 20 years
after Columbine and we all know it we've
got to face the reality that's what
these moments call for if nothing else
can't run you got to be like Riley you
got to be like Kendrick you got to run
at the problem you got to run at the
problem you way to run at the problem is
obviously to do exactly what Chris Cuomo
says you should do politically at the
federal level by the way we should
recall Columbine that he is mentioning
there
1999 you know it was in place at that
time the federal assault weapons ban
from 1994 to 2004 it didn't stop
Columbine so there's that okay time for
some things I like and then some time
for then time for some things that I
hate so things that I like so this is a
thing that I quasi like there is a film
on Netflix called extremely wicked
shockingly evil and vile Zac Efron stars
as Ted Bundy the only issue with this
film really is that it's not about Ted
Bundy so it's like if you heard it was a
movie about Ted Bundy you figured that
it would be is about the sociopath the
sociopathy of Ted Bundy his actual
crimes the victims of the crimes how the
police tracked him down and all of that
it is not about any of those things
virtually the entire movie begins with
Ted Bundy it basically begins with Ted
Bundy's arrest and the movie isn't
really about Ted Bundy it's about Ted
Bundy's girlfriend who's the one who
initially called the police on him and
then was convinced by Ted Bundy that he
wasn't really guilty of all these things
the movie you have the proper
expectation the movie it's good the
movie is really not about him the movie
is really about how if you want to be
misled by the people around you you
certainly can if you take it from that
angle the movies good if you take it as
some sort of biopic of Ted Bundy or some
sort of serious look at Ted Bundy's
crimes that it obviously is not
Zac Efron is very good in the part by
the way he's a really underrated actor
here here is the here's of the preview
ladies and gentlemen of the jury you
have been witness to the unspeakable
horrors of the defendants heinous crimes
you've seen ghastly injuries smashing
faces broken jaws the defendant please
rise for years I've carried as a guilt
but I'm to blame for everything
if we hadn't trusted you promised you'll
never get business it's been another
messy haul isn't it did did you take a
problem with the previews that the
preview makes it sound like it's
actually gonna be about Ted Bundy's
crimes the movie is not about Ted
Bundy's crimes it's about how people
around him accepts head Bundy's crimes
so that is that's an interesting movie
but it's not really being pitched well
so I think you're gonna see people
disappointed and what actually is a
pretty good movie okay time for some
things that I hate okay things that I
hate so a bunch of things that I hate
that are just insanely stupid so the
first thing that is insanely stupid
today there's an article in Vice
about how medical textbooks
overwhelmingly use pictures of young
white men okay now my wife as many
people know is a doctor in fact you can
buy a t-shirt with that slogan on it
from our daily wire store over at Amazon
but the fact is that doctors do not rely
on the pictures in the textbooks when it
comes to diagnosing illness they look at
the bodies in front of them and in fact
doctors work with bodies in front of
them all the time they work in medical
school with cadavers those cadavers are
rarely of young white slim-fit males
because those people don't die all that
often usually it's an older person or a
person who is fatter a person with a
health problem and then I remember my
wife coming home and telling me about
all of this I mean you got a carve
through them that's your actual
experience with the bodies not the
pictures in the textbooks textbooks are
just supposed to show you where things
are basically but according device this
is very very bad and they say that it's
these pictures in the textbooks that are
leading to racial bias in medical care
or alternatively that's not really what
is happening here the editors of human
anatomy the textbook with parody are
Lane mariage and kochia hoenn both women
the textbook with the worst ratio was
edited solely by men what we need now is
gender parity in the editing of medical
textbooks because we have to show bodies
that are diverse why because apparently
doctors are too stupid to understand
that bodies are diverse according to the
Vice article in some cases showing a
female body makes sense if the content
is specifically about female health but
according to this new study even in
cases where there is no reason
show one sex over another men are more
likely to be depicted as the normal body
this lines up with previous research
from 1992 that found that even when it
comes to medical imagery around
reproduction men outnumbered women in
textbooks 2.5 to 1 okay well if there's
no difference between this part of the
medical anatomy why do you care whether
a man is being shown or a woman if
you're looking up one of the appendix is
it's in the same place in men and women
so why does it matter why are you so
concerned about this man if you if
you're pissed off at medical textbooks
let me suggest that you need to you need
to get a life I mean really need to get
a life but speaking of gender parity the
the kind of in-house joke at the New
York Times among opinion columnist is
Farhad Manjoo who has a piece called the
next president should not be a man he
says according to pollsters and
political reporters a dispiriting
dynamic has taken hold of the early
stages of the Democratic presidential
primary voters are discounting female
candidates as unelectable or
alternatively you've provided us a bunch
of crappy candidates maybe it's that
maybe it's that Elizabeth morning Warren
it Sun charming Kamala Harris is a woke
scold and kirsten gillibrand is a joke
maybe it's that but according to firehud
manju it is the innate sexism of the
american people
dave waggle of the washington post says
something similar he says to understand
biden mentum you've got to have some of
the conversations i had yesterday
middle-aged women explaining the 2016
showed that voters won't elect a female
president so they've got to be strategic
or alternatively you could have run a
not crappy candidate Farhad Manjoo says
emotionally such reticence makes sense
Hillary Clinton's lost to a cartoon
misogynist left an enduring wound three
years later the memory feels like a
flashing danger sign a warning that
however some much some may wanted this
country is simply not ready to elect a
woman as president again maybe they're
not ready to elect your woman as
president if nikki Haley were on the
Republican ticket today she would be the
odds-on favorite to win the presidency
Farhad Manjoo says Democrats for your
own sake and the sake of our nation I
beseech you drive away such useless
thoughts overlooking a qualified woman
because you expect misogynist to have a
problem with her is the very definition
of patriarchy you are abdicating the
voting booth to the enemies of equality
and are perpetuating the dynamic that
has given us 45 male presidents in a row
well actually the dynamic they gave us
45 male presidents in a row was that it
was only men voting for the vast
majority of American history or at least
half of men
in history he says that's not all in the
2020 cycles something else is at play
today doubting a candidate's
electability because she's a woman isn't
just unfair it's exactly backward this
year it's the men whose electability you
should doubt so apparently you must
select a woman gender politics are at
the core of all politics says Farhad
Manjoo reawaken feminism should turn
reflexive bias on its head the women who
are running this year are broadly
qualified to occupy the White House
really senator Warren has been in the
Senate for basically one term Kamala
Harris has been in there for five
minutes
kirsten gillibrand again is a joke he
says they've won statewide races they've
survived brutal primaries they've
advanced novel and path-breaking public
policy ideas yes so novel sewn so
path-breaking I mean like the actual
typical Democratic Party agenda for the
last 50 years or radical left ISM he
says common sense tells us electing a
woman as president would deal with
smashing symbolic blow to the patriarchy
I am so tired of this so tired of this
symbolic blows to the payer you're right
you know having to Strich having a
Secretary of State who is a black woman
and Condoleezza Rice I remember the one
the media didn't care about that they
only cared that Hillary Clinton was
Secretary of State having a vice
president vice presidential candidate
who was a woman in Sarah Palin was
mocked by the left Elizabeth Dole ran
for president in 2000 as a Republican
left didn't care about that seems they
only care about quote unquote misogyny
when it's a Democratic woman they want
to see elected okay final thing that I
hate so this is just hilarious Chris
Hughes who is the roommate of Mark
Zuckerberg and made hundreds of millions
of dollars because he was Mark
Zuckerberg roommate he lucked into a
bunch of money because he was an early
investor in facebook as Mark Zuckerberg
roommate in college he did nothing to
earn that money by the way other than be
an early investor good on him he then
bought the New Republic and proceeded to
run it directly into the ground now he
wants Facebook broken up so the company
that made him all the money and that he
doesn't run he wants it broken up now
after it made him all his money how
convenient he's ruined one company why
not ruin another now I am NOT an
advocate of breaking up Facebook I don't
think that it's an actual monopoly it
doesn't have market it doesn't have any
sort of regular
recapture involved I'm in favor of
determining whether Facebook is in fact
a publisher or a or a platform that's
not the same thing as using antitrust
law in inappropriate ways I think
antitrust law quote unquote breaking up
monopolies is far too often over applied
for more on that you can read a book by
Robert Bork about antitrust I think it's
called the antitrust paradox from the
1970s it is still relevant Chris Hughes
this this fool writes the last time I
saw Mark Zuckerberg was in the summer of
2017 several months before the Cambridge
analytical scandal broke we met at
Facebook's Menlo Park California office
and drove to his house in a quiet leafy
neighborhood we spent an hour or two
together while his toddler daughter
cruised around we talk politics mostly a
little about Facebook a bit about our
families when the shadows grew long I
had to head out I hugged his wife
Priscilla and said goodbye to Mark since
then Mark's personal reputation and the
reputation of Facebook have taken a
nosedive it's been 15 years since I
co-founded Facebook at Harvard and I
haven't worked at the company in a
decade but I feel a sense of anger and
responsibility oh or alternatively you
really did nothing at Facebook and Mark
Zuckerberg ran the whole thing and then
you made a lot of money off his back and
now you're being ungrateful and you want
to break it up for virtue signaling
purposes and he talks about his
beautiful relationship with Mark
Zuckerberg
oh yeah and by the way I want to break
up marks company mark is a good kind
person since Chris use but I'm angry
that his focus on growth led him to
sacrifice security and civility for
clicks I'm disappointed in myself and
the early Facebook team for not thinking
more about how the news feed algorithm
could change our culture influence
elections and empower nationalist
leaders right this is really what what
he wants is to restrict the ability to
disseminate speech on Facebook just like
all good little leftists Chris Hughes
would like to see Facebook become a
repository of his ideas and his ideas
alone the government says Chris Hughes
must hold mark accountable for too long
lawmakers have marveled at Facebook's
explosive growth and overlooked their
responsibility to ensure that Americans
are protected and markets are
competitive Facebook's offered to a
points of privacy czar is not enough
neither is a five billion dollar fine he
says we may need to rein him now it's
time to break up Facebook we need
already have the tools we need to check
the domination of Facebook etc etc etc
now I know there are a bunch of people
on the right who don't like Facebook and
so they are happy to do anything that
they can do to break up Facebook or hurt
Facebook I am NOT
anti-facebook I'm anti how Facebook has
applied its own standards and that's why
I think that we should determine whether
in fact Mark Zuckerberg wants to be an
editor-in-chief the way I am a Daily
wire or whether he wants to be the head
of a platform but the fact that Chris
uses saying this I think it's a good
indicator we should not do that and by
the way maybe we should open up Chris
use to liability I mean he was
apparently a very important person at
the company in his formative stages so
if they're really bad maybe he had
something to do with that it's I'm so
tired of the virtue signaling from
people who make money off people who
didn't again Chris who's locked into
this stuff he's getting hit right and
left for this and he should be I mean he
was literally the guy who's randomly
assigned to Zuckerberg freshman dorm
Facebook co-founder all right well we
will be back here a little bit later for
two additional hours of the Ben Shapiro
show so stick around for that or we'll
see you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam SIA
Vettes audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant NIC Sheehan the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey
everybody its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show so now the Democrats
are going to put on a show it's the
impeachment and constitutional crisis
show except without a real impeachment
or a real constitutional crisis because
they need a show to replace the reality
they've lost that's on the Andrew Klavan
trail I'm Andrew Clavin